not again Kelsey ballerini joins the
long list of artists that have recently
been hit in the face while performing on
stage
and going down she did while performing
a concert in Idaho on Wednesday night
the country star had to stop her show
when a concert goer threw what seems to
be a bracelet on stage directly hitting
her in the face
after being hit Kelsey had her back to
the crowd for a while as members of her
bands checked on her and while she tried
to be a good sport by getting the
audience to cheer and sing the words for
her
[Music]
ultimately she was rushed off stage to
tend to the injury
poor Kelsey thankfully a Kelsey
ballerini fan account did assure fans
that the country start was all right but
warned people to be more careful at
concerts tweeting I know we all mean
well we all want to show Kelsey love the
best way we know how and shower her with
all the gifts but throwing things on
stage where artists are already so
vulnerable is not the move please don't
put her in danger like this adding what
we know at this point is that she is
back on stage and okay but please know
that if you do this you're the reason
why we can't have cops on our water
bottles
this is starting to get out of hand
Kelsey joins the likes of BB rexha Ava
Max and pink who have all been startled
by fans throwing items on stage